hey everyone welcome back to day 3 of
gamespot's coverage of CES I'm Peter
Brown here with Justin hey wald and
Justin yesterday you had a chance to get
hands-on with Sony's PlayStation now
service can you explain a little bit
about what your experience was like yeah
so I we already know what PlayStation
now is that it lets you stream
PlayStation 1 PlayStation 2 PlayStation
3 games on to sony bravia tvs onto
playstation 4 onto lots of connected
devices and it's going to be coming out
later this year but actually getting to
try it out myself here on the show floor
and at a special Sony event they're
saying that I was able to play using the
the current PlayStation now servers and
from what I experienced if this is
actually what the service is going to be
like it's it's really lag free the games
look really good they have a couple
games that we were able to try out there
was puppeteer which you know as a
platformer and where that any kind of
delay can be really important that can
really screw up your game in and it
worked really good there was also some
beyond which looked just as good as it
did when I'm playing on my console the
last of us which is also a really
graphic intensive game that that held up
even though it was being streamed
apparently and god of war ascension
which I saw somebody else playing over
on Vita and and also it ran really
really smooth even though it's
apparently being streamed from the
offside servers video is very important
when it comes to streaming video games
but I think a lot of people are
wondering too about the input latency
did you notice anything or any issues or
did it seem like you were actually
playing a PlayStation that was in your
living room if I did not know that it
was on PlayStation now I really would
not have noticed any latency issues at
all however i was told that a lot of
this has to do with your bandwidth if
you don't have a really strong a really
good internet connection your results
are gonna vary and you'll probably want
a minimum of at least five megs up and
down I think that's gonna be one of the
biggest challenges facing Sony for this
global launch whenever it does happen
Justin were you able to find out
anything in terms of pricing
availability in different regions were
they giving out any of that new
information so of course I asked them
when is this going to come to Europe how
much is this gonna cost is it tied into
our PlayStation Plus account and the
answer is no comment all right so we got
some new info Justin thank you for your
time we got lots more Cohen from CES
it's just the start of day 3 stay tuned
for more gaming coverage on Facebook
YouTube and Twitter and Peter Browns
Justin hey wald thanks for watching
you